it's really effing hard to start a
two-sided marketplace and when you do
the prize is a billion dollars uh you
know in your pocket
yeah i feel like i can rule the world i
know i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
my days off on the road let's
travel never looking back all right
what's up uh i was thinking about the
beginning of these
because um if you watch like joe rogan
joe just sort of rolls into the
conversation
it's actually starts like mid-sentence
of what they're
already talking about and i think that's
kind of cool it's pretty casual and then
you have other people
that really try to like brand their
brand their beginning so i'll give you a
couple examples and you tell me which
one you think is a good idea
so um the all-in podcast which i like
is hosted by jason calikanis and then
what he does
is they have the uh what they call the
cold open
which we do sometimes too which is you
pull kind of like the most interesting
or funny one-liner from the middle of
the episode you put it at the beginning
and then you roll into like the intro
song where it introduced
kind of it's like a custom song that
introduces the four people it's like
chamath this black king you know
david friedberg the king the queen of
quinoa or whatever
so that's like one version then there's
you know scott adams the guy who started
dilbert or writes the dilbert comic
he does this thing every time he does a
live and he used to do live streams like
every day or something like that
and he would always say let's start with
a ceremonial sip
and he would like hold up his drink to
the camera he would have you do it too
even though you're not even on camera
you're just
at home he's like everybody let's do
this and cheers
all right here we go and he's like he
talked about it he's like he's big on
neuro-linguistic programming nlp and um
and so he's hypno he's like a trained
hypnotist or something like that
and so he's like you want to like
associate the same
sort of like he's like doing this with
my tea is brilliant or your coffee
because
it has emotion it has a taste it has a
smell
and it has a auditory thing i'm saying
every single time the same exact thing
and so i'm basically programming you for
a certain feeling or emotion
of the life so he's like really you know
going hard at it
um our buddy pomp does the same thing
he's got like his little catch phrase
where he starts he's like bang bang
everybody he does this little finger
thing at the start of every
single video um very specifically does
the same thing every single time so what
do you think about that
uh i like the joe rogan one to just roll
into it don't
try so hard yeah do you agree um i
i definitely think the other one's more
effective but um
but who cares like uh you know
i think if you have to try that hard um
i think it's fine i guess it's fun to do
if it's whatever if you think of
something
but if nothing comes naturally i def i
don't think you should force it
because uh it's just more likely like
awkward than anything else at that point
um
and in general i think that like i
tweeted this out about twitter bios i
don't know if you saw this tweet i did
but
i said here's the twitter bio paradox
and i showed two people side by side
uh one was dan gilbert who's been our
billy of the week before so
like an actual billionaire so i ever
this guy's a baller
and his his bio makes him try to sound
like a regular guy because his
his but his twitter buy was like you
know family man
retired pizza delivery driver you know
trying to make an impact on as many
people as i can and then it's like
at cavs at quicken loans at whatever
like these companies like yeah he owns
an nba team
and like a a 10 to 30 billion dollar
company or whatever
and then i put it but the other side it
just puts up some random guy i had to
snipe some
some guy it didn't mean nothing personal
but i just searched on twitter
forbes thundering into 30 to see who
would be putting that in their bio
because that's the ultimate tell
that you're trying too hard because you
know we've talked about before it
doesn't mean
and um i found this guy who was like
investor
entrepreneur innovator philanthropist
exactly
forbes 30 under 30 finalists which
people were just making fun of him like
dude you weren't even 43
you were a finalist you're like one of
the top 30 000 people or something um
and then it's like you know
international speaker renowned
you know whatever and then and then
mentions like
two companies that he's like you know
started or whatever and nobody's ever
heard of these companies and so i said
on one side you have a baller trying to
act like like trying to counter signal
that he's a regular guy and on the other
side you have a regular guy trying to
signal that he's a baller
and uh you know this is the the paradox
of twitter the harder you try
the more you tell me that you're still
trying and um and you can see this
across the board there's
you know a lot of people have no bio and
the no bio is like
my name speaks for itself you either
know who i am or i don't care i've
achieved so much fame that i'm not
trying to impress you
so uh i think that's a pretty
interesting tell and and i like the
the term that somebody pointed out for
which was signaling and counter
signaling
they're actually both signaling the rich
guy's trying to signal
the rich guy's trying to signal i'm just
like you don't mind me don't hate me
and then the other guy is trying to say
i'm bigger than i am right but both are
both are signaling
oh you wanna do some questions yeah
let's do it all right um i'm gonna ask
you a question
that people asked us um this is a funny
question
i don't know if i want to answer this
we'll let you do it um
oh dan compiled some all right dan but
let me ask one first
what's it like to be rich
[Laughter]
yeah it's sweet it's sweet because
you don't have to worry about a bunch of
things and so yeah
it doesn't take away all your worries
but it takes away all your money worries
so if you've ever like you know
boom you get hit with a like my car was
in an accident it's like oh i'm
gonna have to pay like thousands of
dollars to get this repaired
if i didn't have money lying around
that's a that
that can ruin a day real quick they can
ruin a week real quick they can ruin a
month
and so yeah it's sweet to not have to
have a certain set of worries um or
things that just are downers
do you have a number so we what's
interesting is that you know there's
this idea of having a number of like i'm
ready to retire
and like a lot of studies have been done
and very like interestingly
a lot of people will have a number that
they're at and then if you double it
that's what they like on average people
say look so if you have five million
dollars
like uh if i had ten i'd be happy if
only i had ten yeah yeah or if
i have ten if i had twenty i'd be happy
which is always kind of funny
it's like three inches in height
everybody wants three inches in height
right do you
did you have a number do you have a
number uh yeah i did
and then some people who were way past
that were like dude that number is not
enough
uh your number was six i used to say six
million
uh because i'd done some calculations
and i was like oh six six should do it
where
what i was trying to calculate was if i
had six that was uh like
working for me six million invested i
was saying okay with x
you know average annual return does that
cover my life burn even if my life burn
was twice what it is today
and and people were like yeah but
uh you know that rate of return is a
little bit
like too optimistic and your life burn
is going to go up more
you just haven't really figured that out
yet yeah you know the more money you
have the higher your life burn's gonna
go
it's hard to really be disciplined about
that so do you have a number now
yeah so now i think the number is um
i don't know i think 20 is the number
where
i would now have to like think of
different ways that like why
money matters um why why more money
would matter to me
um like all the obvious things would be
more than taken care of at 20 million so
what's funny is
i've talked about this with uh as well
and
the people at 20 say the same thing 40
maybe a 40.
maybe at 40. so i don't know when that
when that stopped because i used to take
one and then i used to think six and
then once you get there you're like okay
you're at six well no six this is i'm
not i can't stop here right
20. maybe at 20 and then maybe at 20
i'll do the same thing what do you think
it is
um so i think it definitely is like
um yeah 15 to 20 like if you have
15 20 million dollars at a really young
age like
you know let's say 31 uh like it's
you're set it's hard to lose it's hard
yeah i could
i could lose 10 million and still have
10 million um
so like it's hard to lose now you're not
flying private
but you're living a really nice life and
you're never going to work again but
here's the thing
guys like i don't know about you but
guys like me even though i say i'm not
going to work anymore i'm
always going to work um and because work
is play
so i have someone who can earn 20
million
at a young age i think they're set
regardless because they're always going
to be able to earn
that's a very good point age the age
definitely matters because it's all
about
sort of how many years of compounding
are you going to get from there
um and i was doing the math basically
like at a seven and a half percent
return so like if you believe that the
trailing hundred years is going to
repeat itself for the next hundred years
then you can if you believe that that's
that's to be true
then your money will double around not
every nine years
so 20 at 30 becomes 40 at uh
40 which becomes 80 at 50 which becomes
160 at 60 and that becomes a billion by
the time you're 90
which is kind of wild how about now the
question is like well when we're 90 like
is a billion even gonna
mean you know that much who knows
but like that that growth is quite
phenomenal and that's really hard to
grasp unless you put it in front of you
so getting wealthyish at a young age i
think is very
significant um yes okay so that's fine i
don't know i feel like i gave kind of a
generic answer which was
what's it like to be rich i guess like i
didn't what what i'm glad i didn't do
was say
oh you know it's not as it's not as good
as you think
uh which a lot of people say a lot of
british people will say you know
i thought it'd be great but then i
realized that what really matters is
family it's like yeah dude i know that
family matters right i'm asking what the
rich part of the experience is like you
know how's that
how's that been for you and uh and i
guess what i would say is like
rich whatever rich means to you you know
the main the main benefit from my
perspective
is that there are just certain things
you don't have to concern yourself with
or work
or worry about anymore um you know the
biggest being
if i don't want to work or i don't want
to go to this job i can just not do that
i can do something else with my time
right like
the money has freed up time time can be
now invested in
any activity you want and that tends to
be like
you're picking that now you're picking
stuff you really enjoy or you think
really makes an impact
rather than you know something you have
to do in order to pay next month's bill
andrew asked outside of business this is
andrew wilson what do you research and
read about i'll go first
i read a ton of history i love american
history starting in around 1860 going
all the way up to about
1950. uh i think that's when crony
capitalism kind of
came to uh that kind of went away in all
the regulations that came into place in
america it kind of came to be
and a lot of interesting stuff was going
on there i also love
reading and listening about the mafia
because i think what the mafia did
is like as american as apple pie like
it's so fascinating to me so i read a
ton of history
and i research a ton a ton of uh or like
early american stuff so i'd like to go
to museums and
and look at old architecture from that
era wow we couldn't be more different
all right so outside of business i would
break it into three groups
i study or research what the nerds
are into right now so anytime you know
smart friends who are kind of like
technically minded if they're into
something
i it takes me probably five times longer
than them just to understand that
that new technology but uh i put in that
time because
i like it and um so like you know
somebody will mention something that hey
you know
um this ai thing you know is now able to
predict protein folding
and i'll be like protein folding i don't
know what the proteins fold for
what's protein folding all about what
have people tried before
how do they even get this to work what
is actually machine learning how does
that work
you know like and so i try to i try to
basically study what the nerds study
that's one
two is more of like the unwinding which
is sports
i'm like knee-deep in basketball you
know
uh stuff so i like to follow all the
storylines
stats you know that sort of thing uh and
then the last one that i would say
is self-help or some kind of like
mindset so i think that
uh you know people probably at this
point if you listen to this podcast you
know that
um more than anything i'm a believer
that
if you can master your mind you've won
the game and
i think that that's the hardest hardest
thing to master is your mind and i want
to
read all the different ways people do
that and try them and self-experiment
and then
go back and research more so that's the
third thing i do
how did success influence or change the
dynamics of your romantic relationships
that's a good question but we both have
been um from uh
julie julie davila yes
julie had that was a good question best
question so far so
i was i met my wife right when i started
my company
and um before that i dated a ton
i i was okay big dog i was i'm not
saying it was successful
let me change that i tried to date a
time
yeah uh so i tried to i i liked women
um it didn't always work but uh i prefer
being in a relationship
uh being successful has been cool with
my wife
because it feel because we are manage
our success together
and like i think for both of us our
wives were successful before we were
yeah my wife yeah were at least way more
liquid
they made they made more money faster
than we than we did dude
i'll say it i mean my wife was a
self-made liquid millionaire
before i was right uh yeah i think
i think same same is true for me so so
that was uh
that's the first part like you know how
it was really you know
how was success for them was the real
question i was like
working marrying this broke you know
broke entrepreneur who keeps trying to
say he's living the big dream but you
know where's the
where's the success for like you know
it's five years that that's
that's the first question so yeah when i
dated sarah
her mom was like so does he and her
parents are entrepreneurs so they kind
of got it but like does he have a job
like well no he's trying to start this
conference thing
or where does he work well he can he
works on his laptop he could work
anywhere
and they didn't get it and so my first
year i made like
20 grand and then like 50. like he's a
wedding planner i think
yeah like so anyway like
my wife had a full-time job and she was
probably making six figures straight out
of college she went to an ivy league
school and went to facebook
anyway how has it changed the dynamics
it's made it
my opinion way better i do we do all of
our finances together we meet once a
week and we go everything do you do
when i started when i started dating my
wife she um
she had just bought her first house she
was driving a bmw
m3 sport i was living under my parents
house in a like
they had like an unpermitted in-law unit
that i
lived in with my my best friend from
high school who
lived in there with me and uh you know
that's where that's where i was he
didn't have a car didn't have a house
uh i had a job i had a good job i guess
but um
but yeah that's that's how we were when
we met and then you know
great what does he do he's the ceo of a
startup okay so
you know he's virtually virtually
unemployed you know like
on the brink of unemployment essentially
was a situation
i'll say one thing which is as you know
as good things started to happen
so got got promoted from like a product
manager to
ceo of like the company and then from
ceo to like
you know investing and then selling the
company and all that stuff there was
definitely a period where i got a little
cocky
um where not intentionally but i look
back now and i'm like i was kind of
kind of being a dick i sort of thought
all these people
i hang out with that are like you know
super successful i felt like they they
didn't have to deal with any of the
at home that i was dealing with
it's like okay yeah i gotta take out the
trash
you know does my investor take out the
trash i don't know maybe he's got
somebody takes out the trash for him
right like
oh i have to you know wake up at like
right now i wake up in the morning at
seven o'clock and from seven to ten am
i you know i'm on daddy duty taking care
of the baby and i was sort of like don't
were we supposed to have like nannies
for this i was like very uh spoiled
in that sense and i thought well no i'm
the like successful working guy right so
like
i don't have to do these like normal
things and so that was my like
entitlement to myself
and then i realized two things one is uh
yeah those guys do that too that's you
know a lot of the people that i was
talking about that i admire they did all
that too they just didn't complain about
it like a little
and then the second thing was that they
um
that like who cares like do whatever uh
do whatever works for you and your
family and like stop being stop
holding your time as more valuable than
my wife's time or that my kid's time or
my dog's time or anybody else i used to
kind of you're talking
i used to think my time was the most
precious and now i don't now i'm sort of
like
you know it's our time we got to use it
how we want
do you i think it's cool we're both
married i think it's cool to have this
like team mentality you know when
my wife and i so i i we're both catholic
and even though we don't practice
anything i
was like we have to get married in a
catholic church it was important to me
and what that means is you got to meet
with the priests and he was like so why
are you getting married
and we were like well we have similar
values in life
we have the same goals we just we both
want to take over everything
we um want to have children and raise
them in a particular type of way
we want to share our assets and pull
together and he's like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
what about love you guys love each other
and we're like oh yeah yeah yeah that
too
and so like for us it was definitely we
definitely love each other but also
there was a functional partnership
yeah it's like it's very this is a very
practical way to like live go through
life like it's very
it's easier for one another when you
have someone that who's family you can
count on them no matter what they're
gonna have your back
so anyway i've enjoyed uh having a
little bit of success
while being uh married if you're single
i guess the pros could be like you could
just like
fool around with people way out of your
league but i do think that it would be
exhausting
and actually probably not as fulfilling
but maybe more fun
man i look back now when i use i was
single you know i was 25 years old
single didn't own a possession in the
world and i was managing
a bunch of people who were 10 20 years
older than me had kids had families had
mortgages had all the stuff
and i thought at the time i was being
super understanding about it
and now when i look back i'm like oh my
god i was such a
idiot like i just didn't understand how
how hard it is for these people to give
this much to a startup
um when they have all these
responsibilities and obligations at home
and i was you know just a free bird 25
years old and you know
i could piss my time away it didn't
matter and like for these people that
extra one hour they were at work was now
through off the whole dinner time
bedtime schedule for them their kids
their wife you know like all this stuff
and so i just look back now and i you
know i apologize to anybody i worked
with then
because i didn't truly understand i
thought you know this hustle culture was
there was the right answer then and now
and i didn't realize how much they were
already giving uh and i always wanted
more
what um yeah let's do two more um what
pandemic behavior do you want to
maintain
um yeah basically the last year was
you know it sounds insensitive so
whatever maybe that's that's the case
but
last year was the best year of my life
um same you know i had a blast
and a whole bunch of life events
happened right i had a kid i became a
dad and
you know but i just everything i grew up
my hair i built a home gym i started
working out regularly i
you know um you know i'm working from
home so i just had
way more time with my family with my
wife uh than when i was commuting every
day and
was at the office all day um you know
this podcast has been a lot of fun this
has been like 10 amazing things that
happened this year that made this year
literally the best year of my life
so uh in terms of pandemic behavior i
would say
i definitely don't like getting close to
people and shaking their hands anyway so
you know good i'm just going to keep not
doing that but i would say like the home
gym
daily workout at 1 pm is definitely the
behavior i need to like keep going with
i agree i've i've gotten in wonderful
shape throughout this
and uh that's the one i'm going to
maintain yeah um
all right last one maybe um i'm curious
about this favorite purchase one
all right uh okay let's do
let's do three of these let's do um
if you were 21 again what would you be
doing i can't stand that question but
i'll answer
it yeah what is it if i was 21 now in
i don't i don't know what would let me
think what would you be what would you
do
i think i would go on tour with
in the most like interesting spaces with
the most interesting people so i think
what i would do is i would say hey
i'm a hired gun you pay me
whatever pay me 5k a month 10k a month
something like that
uh flat fee i'm gonna come work my ass
off for you
uh for three months if i love it i'll
stay on
but by default you're gonna get just
like somebody unbelievable just right
hand man to
to deal with any headaches or problems
you have and you'll never see somebody
you know work harder and smarter at
figuring out than me
and i would pick basically like four or
five people that i thought were amazing
um that were doing things in interesting
fields doing interesting projects
and i would pitch that to them and i
would if they said no i would find the
next five people and i would just
i would go on tours i would when i would
treat 21 i would treat work
like a tree i would treat um like
marriage in the sense that i would focus
on dating
figure having fun figuring out what i
love what i like figuring out what likes
me
and um i would be in no rush to like
find the project or start the company or
like pick a career
i would say cool i'm gonna go on i'm
gonna have these these little
three-month relationships
with badass people in badass bases and
um you know just just i commit to doing
that for two years and then i'll figure
it out after that like a
that'll be my mormon mission i would
probably
my goal at 21 would be how to become a
liquid millionaire by 25 and then after
25 i could dedicate
a little bit more time to like a big
purpose or how do i create cash flow
and so i think i would want to start a
blog or something like that and try to
sell it
in the next two or three years i would i
would not try to do that because
um i think that you know
if we're measuring the score on like a i
don't know 10
year period or 20 year period then i
think i would get more value by
being at the cutting edge of certain
spaces certain industries
and being seeing what like like a
plus plus players are like when i work
with them and earning their trust
i think that's a lot more valuable all
right last question best
purchase over two grand and under 100
over two grand for me got to be
uh this rowing machine that i bought for
about two thousand dollars
it's called ergata i am obsessed with it
or i bought a
pretty nice uh mercedes that's really
fast i go on drives every
morning and in the afternoon and it just
makes me happy
for under a hundred dollars
uh under i don't i don't know
uh i i have to think what about you
i would say this camera that i'm using
right now um
because when the whole world went remote
everything's done over video
and yeah i used to just use like a mac
air
mac air laptop makes you look like you
know an actual like prisoner of war
in uganda when you go on a video call
and so
uh this having a dope camera is great
for the pod but it's great for every
single meeting i feel like
i feel like i'm putting my best forward
and i look great i feel great i think
the other person
you know treats you differently
depending on how you show up and so i
think this one camera is like
the equivalent of buying you know a
closet full of
ten thousand dollar suits you know and
without any of the headache of like
wearing a suit so my under 100
is an aeropress i love my aeropress what
does it love it that's a coffee thing
it's a coffee
coffee thing it's like a it makes
individual cups coffee is badass i use
it all the time
uh under a hundred dollars okay i got
this for free from jack smith jack gave
me his thera gun
and i love the thera gun um yeah
he gave it to you
yeah he had like an old one or something
like that he he he he got a new one or i
don't know what i don't know why he
i had to go buy a knockoff on amazon
yeah that's what i was gonna do
and actually then he messaged me was
like hey i have one i'll send it to you
and i was like oh i'll buy it and he's
like no no just what's your address i'll
send it to you and i was like jack good
guy
and now i told i sent him a message i
was like dude i use this thing every
night i think of you
every night because i'm like i love this
gun i love jack for giving me this gun
this thing is amazing
do you want um do you want an update on
some numbers
yeah so this month may
may is over now but in may we're doing a
podcast push
so we got about 630 000 listens
so that was the number we were uh to put
that in perspective that's
plus i think 34 39 month over month
and so that's 40 month from
april to may and then the month before
april march
march to april was a 30 and then the
month before was also a 30
right so basically since you started
saying i'm going to focus on growth this
thing started growing between 30 and 40
month over month we've doubled in the
time that you said i remember we were at
300 something thousand then now we're at
600 something thousand yeah
downloads per minute now i don't think i
think
june might be stable the reason why is
because i don't think people are going
to be listening as much
i saw a distinct drop on monday
like mondays we normally have 35 000
listeners this monday was 18 000.
right so i think i think we might hit a
little trough of sorrow but that's okay
we gotta know to expect that but we're
gonna
keep training but i think that we're
gonna hit a million soon
and here's some more stats our top
rating we are number eight in itunes and
in spotify in the business category
which is pretty good
number eight number eight wow uh we are
at number eight still right now on
spotify and for some reason
we were number one in britain in the
investing category i have no idea why
uh but that's the updated numbers i'm
pretty proud i think you should be proud
too
um a few things that people loved trungs
thing was amazing people loved
his your short ones people loved um
you did one today on but that was june
but yeah people liked it so far i think
yeah um i uh i'm gonna i'm i'm posting
that on youtube but i'm
because it's like my story i'm gonna put
that on my youtube i think i deserve
that
and i think that uh that's gonna go
viral
but uh the numbers were good we grew a
lot it's working
i think the best thing you said was to
there will be a plateau whether it's
this month or the next month there's
always a plateau
and i've talked about this before which
was one of the biggest
lessons learned as somebody trying to
build is that
these plateaus happen you should you
know i used to
think oh plateau means the you know the
world is the sky is falling
this isn't working uh you know change
everything
no uh blah blah blah and it's like no
you know the dabbler
quits and goes and does a different
thing the stressor gets freaked out by
the plateau thinks that they did
something wrong and takes it personally
and the master says oh there you are i
thought you'd be here soon hello
uh and then sort of dances with the
plateaus and figures out how to get to
the next level again so i think we're
gonna probably plateau somewhere here in
the
six to seven hundred thousands per month
before we shoot through the million per
month
and i was working with my wife yesterday
she wants to launch a course
you've inspired her shawn and she was
all excited to start this thing she's
been talking for a month it's a great
idea and yesterday she was
like halfway through recording the
content and everything and she was like
i feel horrible i'm like
ah you're there right right you're there
i'm like the 40
park yes yes and i like i talked to her
and i was teasing with her but i was
like sarah do you know why i'm good at
what i do
is because i know that that is normal
and i keep going
and you know why most people are not uh
what who they want to be is that's where
they stop right but so what you have to
know is that point where you you start
high and then you get to low when you're
a little bit into it
you have to a recognize that's very
normal that is incredibly normal and
then
you keep going just like if you're
exercising you're like oh i'm starting
to sweat
i'm starting to sweat it's like oh okay
that's normal that's part of it now you
got to keep going keep going
right right right exactly if you if you
put down the the butt you know the the
dumbbell
every time your muscles started to burn
you would nev never
you never grow right because the burn is
right where it starts you know
the growth starts and so i think for
pre-launch
there's three points everybody hits that
the first time you hit them you react
pretty poorly
typically uh the first is the
overthinking phase that's before you get
started
the second is the this is the the
the the despair this is never gonna work
this sucks
uh the thing i was so excited about now
that i'm doing it
and it's harder than i thought
is this ever going to be good that's
where your wife's at right now yeah and
then there's the last bit when you're at
the 90
mark and the perfectionist comes out and
says no no no no
it's not good enough yet people aren't
going to like this it's not going to
work and you're actually at the 90 to 95
percent mark and
the perfectionist wants to pull you back
to 50 and say no no we need to do
all this other stuff before we go out
there so i think those three points
overthinking
then the point of despair and then the
um
the perfectionist point they have been
pre-launched of every project
yes so it's very normal um so let's talk
about a couple ideas which i think
you're gonna you've got some stuff
yeah by the way also the live shows are
happening i guess by the time this gets
released they'll have already happened
so
you know whatever but after this like
literally
i might have to keep this ten minutes
short because i gotta pack my bag i'm
coming to your house in austin and then
we're going to miami it's gonna be
awesome
can i just say that i think this is
gonna be a game changer for us
i think that we're gonna see it's gonna
be fun to see these
excited people you know what's crazy is
shawn and i like planned to do this like
two weeks ago or we've been talking
about it and then one day he texted me
he goes do you want to go to miami for
this time and we were going to go to
crash someone's event i don't even know
but we just said
pocket yeah in done it's subtle like we
did over at text
and then we got everyone rallied around
it and
i think a hundred people ish are gonna
come to the austin one and then
i think we're at 500 for miami and it
wasn't
until today that i thought and we're
speaking tomorrow so recording this on a
wednesday but you're hearing it on
friday
it wasn't until just now when i right
before the podcast i
told dan what to do but i was like oh i
guess we have to figure out what we're
going to say
right what are we going to talk about so
i told dan i go dan
send out a google form to all the
attendees and just have three things
what look what city you're in uh what
question you want answered
and what your first name is and then
we'll just like see the trends of
questions and then
maybe we can just rattle i think you
told me that idea and and and we'll just
rattle that off
but uh yeah it's cool man you know like
what if this
this sounds so lame because it's just
internet nerds like you and me but what
if like
me oh and jack butcher's coming now uh
what if like me you and jack and andrew
and all these like
like these losers online yeah if we had
like a nerds on tour i'm pretty sure we
could get like 10
000 people to come to each one yeah yeah
i think nerds on tour is a cool idea
i think we should just do it uh maybe
you know
early next year we go nerds on tour uh
that's actually a great idea it's
isn't it funny how the name is great dan
let's grab that domain nerds on tour
let's see if that's available right now
all right you want to uh what do you got
what do you got okay so let's do some
ideas
um okay so neighborhood 7-elevens so
what is i
love neighborhood 7-elevens by the way
so i don't know what kind of
neighborhood you live in i'll find out
when i go to your house tonight but
uh my neighborhood is kind of like i'm
in the suburbs
and so i don't know in this neighborhood
there might be 100 homes
and there's like a gate at the front
it's sort of like one of those
neighborhoods where it takes you
seven minutes to just get from your
house to the front of the neighborhood
because you're
you know you want to go to the grocery
store the grocery store is only two
miles away but like
takes you seven minutes to get out of
your neighborhood and then another ten
minutes to get there it's 17 minutes
like round trip
and um and there's just like a hundred
of these neighborhoods or a thousand of
these neighborhoods in the suburbs like
everywhere i go
in the suburbs of california it's like
this and so i started thinking about
uh two two ideas that came together as
one in my head so
the first was there's a startup we had
talked about called bridge no more
and yeah we talked when we talked about
that it was like just starting i'm
pretty sure it's a huge thing already
well they just raised yeah 15 20 million
dollars or something like that
um love those guys and uh you know was
considering investing i just thought the
value is a little high but
uh but yeah anyways i i think it's
really cool concept and their concept is
it's called fridge no more because like
look in the future you won't even need a
fridge
why because when you want something
you'll just push a button you want like
you know
two ice creams great they'll show up at
your door in like under 15 minutes
how do we do that well we have these
like super small
kind of like cloud uh corner stores that
are
just like we'll have like a hundred in
every city and these cloud corner stores
will be
able to dispatch an order to you in a
very small amount of time with a very
low
um like delivery fee and uh and go puff
does this on college campuses that's
like a
multi-billion dollar company i think and
so i started thinking about in the
suburbs
the challenge uh is a little bit
different and i thought why don't
neighborhoods
just have a neighborhood corner store
okay well how would that work
so you told me about the vending
machines thing last podcast so it got me
thinking okay
that was a good one right that was a
good one as i was driving through my
neighborhood i was like look at all
these garages like
would somebody not want 500 a month
to turn their garage or part of their
garage into basically just like
fridges and freezers and then
it could just get you know basically you
just deliver to the
uh you deliver to the neighborhood
garage that's the neighborhood corner
store
all the bulk wholesale goods you know
your your water your
all your drinks your sodas your uh
snacks
and your like ice creams or whatever and
then in the neighborhood
you would just have it where you just
order and either you go pick it up uh
out of the girl out of that garage or
you know some kid in the neighborhood
can just pick up the order make five
bucks for just taking it from one part
of the neighborhood to the other
uh to bring it to you and uh the key
would be the convenience of the speed of
this that you could get it in like
you know under 10 minutes to get
something delivered to you
so basically the idea is take the idea
of 711 but use the sharing economy so
put
put a mini 711 inside of garages inside
of all these suburban neighborhoods what
do you think of this idea
i've got strong feelings so before
um well just let me let me let me get to
it the sharing economy
so kind of really got popular with
airbnb
uber i remember 2013 in the same way
that all the older school magazines are
all talking about crypto
it was like the sharing economy so
there's a sharing economy for everything
back in 2013 2014 and it was all we
talked about
and i've looked at the data and i've
like tried to figure
all this out i am almost positive
that the sharing economy only works for
like two or three things
uber and driving um airbnb
home rentals and maybe that's it
i've seen sharing economy stuff have you
ever seen
i just got pitched on this the other day
and i just can never get i never am on
board with it
sharing economy for like youtube like
tools and your yeah
this idea has been around and recycled
like a trillion times like hey
why do i have to buy a drill my neighbor
has a drill
you know i just want to use it once why
don't i just rent the drill on demand
locally that idea never works or at
least
it hasn't ever and there's probably a
reason why it hasn't
um there's a bunch of these sharing
economy things like
one was like you go to someone's home
and you cook dinner with them or they
like
a private like if it's a cooking lesson
you know right even airbnb
experiences doesn't really work that
well as a business it works as a nice
little add-on thing for them but that's
not like where their value is
um and i've always thought that sharing
economy
for most things is a horrible idea
i used to share an office when i first
started my company it was me sieva
and one other company i think they were
called rooster or something
and they were trying to get people to
make it was like
storage so they were like wanted people
to rent storage in other people's garage
and i would hear these guys on their
phone trying to call
constantly trying to get and they had
zero users and i heard them trying to
get user one user two i heard all the
whole thing they would walk around on
the phone
it was so hard to convince anyone
and when they did convince someone it
never worked
and so in terms of sharing economy stuff
and like uh
like this idea i'm almost always default
to
i don't know that seems really difficult
do you agree
um i don't agree with uh okay i do agree
that it's difficult
but uh like on the storage one so for
people who don't know there was a
a batch of startups all trying to do
this which was hey
airbnb lets you rent out the excess
space in your bedrooms
your house um why don't we rent let you
rent out
excess space in your garage and so omni
started this way they ended up shutting
down after raising a bunch of money
um clutter tried to do the same thing
clutter changed
i believe they've made it but maybe they
pivoted i don't know what
it's now just a normal ass like we come
pick up your stuff and store it in a
warehouse
distorted warehouses okay so yeah so i
don't know what the uh
what what went wrong there but that was
one that i would believe
could work right because if i have extra
space blah blah and these things you
don't get they don't get used very much
so they sort of just stay in storage for
the most part
there's one reason why i mean and i and
i've thought about this
convenience it's all about convenience
so it's the convenience
that has to pay for itself so uh having
someone stay in my house is
relatively inconvenient but i could make
like
three grand a month pretty consistently
right
okay yeah so it's not about convenience
it's about money well no it's a balance
it's it's like it's my convenience at a
price
now having someone store in my
garage for 80 a month which is how much
it costs to store stuff at a normal
uh storage unit that's just not
worth it i don't
it's not worth it to me it's a pain in
the ass and it's not worth it it's way
too inconvenient
right yeah so i think there is you know
this trade-off i would also say i think
a lot of people merge these ideas
together so
for example sharing economy what does
share economy mean
it means taking excess resources that
are unutilized and getting them to be
utilized right airbnb
excess space get them to be utilized
then there's like
gig economy gig economy is like
more like uber um right like push a
button
and uh like push a button the guy's
gonna come pick you up
and it's not so much excess resources
because that guy it's not like that guy
was just
happened to be driving by anyways it's
like no he just made this his job
um and gig economy so then people
started trying to do that with like
masseuses right like push button a
masseuse will come to your house
um you know like pedicures at your house
or whatever whatever every every random
thing
and then there's sort of like creator
economy which is like a totally
different thing altogether
and so people started just like using
these words pretty interchangeably and i
think
that doesn't work and in general almost
all these are two-sided marketplaces
which are just
like effing hard to do it's really
effing hard to start a two-sided
marketplace and when you do
the prize is a billion dollars you know
in your pocket and so
you know it shouldn't be it really
shouldn't be that easy but uh i agree
so i agree with you that this probably a
wouldn't work or
b uh would be like a real pain in the
ass to do
but good idea sean yeah but interesting
idea in the sense that
um i think it would be pretty
game-changing in terms of convenience
because it would be essentially like a
cold vending machine
inside of neighborhoods right like you
know like a super vending machine inside
of neighborhoods
and if you could get it to work you now
have every sort of suburban neighborhood
uh you know to go spread into where
uh a lot of stuff is done in cities
partly because the
people who build startups tend to live
in cities not in the burbs
and so um so a lot of stuff works in the
cities because that's where they live
that's what they know and then people
are really densely packed into one area
and so it's hard to get things to work
at a neighborhood level you ever been to
a
truck stop where they have like just a
slab of concrete with benches and like
10 different vending machines all right
there were just like an awning
and then you could we'll just do that
let's just do that in the burbs we're
just going to get that slab and put all
those vetting machines right in there
well that's the thing like the question
is what would you sacrifice
one home for right because you need the
space so either it's got to go inside of
a home
right in the garage in the backyard and
inside the house or
it has to be so valuable that you could
justify just buying one of the homes and
converting it into some like commerce
basically for the neighborhood and
getting the permits to do it which is
you know once we start talking permits
it's time to change ideas okay i got
another
i got another suburban idea for you so
um the new golf so my buddy ben
got invited to go play in this pickup
game is pick a basketball game
and uh it's he didn't want to turn it
down because it was like
like ballers yeah there's a bunch of
ballers that were like gonna go play
there there's like basic baller not real
ballers well half
half were actual like you know like good
ballers and
you know people who are like you know
this guy's gonna get drafted this year
this guy trains
the nba players what the isn't ben
like a little guy
yeah but we met the guy who's the
trainer for the nba players this guy
alex
and i forgot his company name last time
so i'll shout out this time through the
lens he's the one building the master
class for athletes
so um through the lens so anyways alex
was organizing this game and he was like
hey you wanna go come play in this
you're i know you're in new york also so
uh come by and if you're if you're a nba
fan you always see on instagram
all the nba players in the summer go
play in this one gym that's like um
it's like in an apartment building so
it's like yeah my my friend used to live
in that building
like sky or something i don't know what
it's called but it's like yeah
it's in new york yeah it's like this
exclusive thing and it'll be like lebron
and carmelo and kevin durant all playing
in this like
little gym whatever so the guy was like
hey
we're gonna go play tomorrow on that gym
you wanna come he's like yeah like
all right who's there and it's like a
bunch of like
you know i don't know billionaires
children and like you know
want to be nba players or whatever so
they went and played and i was like how
was it he's like i was good but like you
know hey i suck
and b um you know i'm just trying not to
get hurt right like
he's like once you know you're 30 you
got like i just had a kid like i just
can't afford to get hurt
and i'm not playing regularly so i'm you
know i just kind of like played it easy
i guess
which is kind of lame but that was the
truth i said well you know same here i
basically played basketball as like my
favorite thing to do
until i was like 27 and then like since
then i've just been like well
the odds of me spraining an ankle or
spraining a knee is just too high i
can't like
actually play the sport anymore properly
and so i kind of opted out
so i started thinking about like at
every age there's a different sport
that's like right for you
so you know maybe in your 20s and 30s it
could be something like basketball or
soccer
in your 40s you really there's not many
45 year old like pick up basketball
players that are that are going out
there there's always you know maybe the
one old dude
who's like barely barely moving but for
the most part
you need to graduate to another sport
that is that matches your
life athleticism so it might be tennis
and you know a little bit older might be
golf
and then a little bit older like i think
that the sort of end sport is basically
uh just playing poker you can just do
that in a wheelchair and
you know it's like the last thing you
can do as like some kind of form of
sport or competition
and so uh so anyways it got me thinking
like
okay if i'm i'm about to shift into the
like tennis phase okay
cool fine uh pickleball bro
so then i started thinking about
pickleball because i was like what is
pickleball pickleball
is mini tennis that is like kind of the
best of tennis but it's also
easier on the body right am i right
about pickleball i haven't played yeah
that's what i see
okay you don't have to run no i would
say it's as hard on the body
but it's like it requires close to no
skill right so okay the skill cap might
be different
uh but i also think there's less less
running around and jumping into it
but like anyone can do it right so so
it's more accessible that's kind of the
point
and then i was thinking about golf
because i think once you hit i don't
know 50 plus
it seems like golf is the major sport
for that age
and golf is like the least
accessible thing right it's
super expensive it takes the whole day
it's hard as to like even be decent
at golf
um so i'm like how is it it's amazing to
me this even worked right like it's
kind of like mind-blowing golf even even
has any popularity so what's the point
what's the new one
what is the new golf so can i tell you
what i've been using yeah what are you
doing
i when i have friends in town or uh you
and i won't have enough time
maybe we will tomorrow but uh like i had
a friend named brennan come over
whenever people visit
uh i go um 5 5 p.m
thursday or whatever come to my house
and wear tennis shoes
and i've bought tons and tons of wraps
and so they get there i throw them hand
wraps and i go
we're gonna box today and i throw them
their thing and we wrap up our hands up
i go all right we're gonna warm up with
some mitts i'll show you how to punch we
do that
and then i go all right here's an extra
mouth guard we're sparring
uh and uh i i lead him
and i we don't hit hard yeah uh but like
if they want every once in a while i
won't hit them hard in the face but i'll
get up in there and then i'll pop them
really hard in the stomach just so they
could feel alive
yeah they feel what it's like to be
alive and then i'll let them punch me i
had a guy to chip my tooth the other day
and it's been the greatest bonding
experience i've done it with men
women everyone with the women like well
she'll pop me real hard and i'll hit her
in the stomach
like it's awesome man it is awesome
i've loved doing this with boxing it
brings you together it makes you feel
alive
and it's a fun sport because we could do
it in my garage and you normally don't
box because it's embarrassing to try
that
in front of a bunch of people are you
afraid to get killed yeah
yeah and i know we're not gonna like and
they'll see me i go put i go put your
hands up watch
and we'll i like my moves so slow i'll
just kind of tap them i'm like look
that's all we're doing we're just gonna
barely touch each other
yeah so i think in the i think 30s maybe
even 40s boxing works i think beyond
that
uh boxing also doesn't work because you
know for obvious reasons
um so so i think you're you're doing the
thing where you're basically as you
shift in age you like
shift in sport um and i've seen like
i think i talked about this once before
but like people have taken like
so so i was talking to my friend sahil
uh this guy saw him bloom people might
have seen him on twitter he's got a big
twitter now
and uh we were we were eating and he was
talking about he used to be a baseball
player at stanford
he's a pitcher and he's like you know i
got hurt
you know that kind of ended my pro
aspirations and then it was sort of like
well this thing the sport i've dedicated
myself to forever
is pretty much useless to me at this
point right like
i will never play pick up baseball like
what am i going to do go find nine
friends on one side nine on the other
side that all like baseball
in the ass all i have four hours to kill
and uh
you know we have the right skills where
we can like pitch and catch uh you know
like
most people can't even sit in the
catcher's squat like you know it's just
you're never going to play baseball
again
and that's true like baseball is sort of
the worst trend worst
access sport at an early age i think
golf is the worst one at a later age
and so i think that if somebody could
take the characteristics that make golf
work
and create their version of pickleball i
think you'd own a pretty valuable asset
and i'm on the lookout
to see what is this next one because i
have several friends that didn't invent
pickleball
but when pickleball started to get
popular they built pickleball businesses
some you know uh i can't say their names
they actually they've
like literally asked me not to but uh
one of them is
they did equipment so like they just
built like you know like an amazon
fba business selling pickleball stuff
and they were able to rank at the top
because at the time pickleball wasn't
that competitive but it got more and
more popular over time
and then other people started leagues
and there's other people that are bar
stools i think doing something on the
media side i don't know there's
a bunch of different ways you can ride
these waves of new sports
and so what makes golf work is that it's
i think it's outdoors
um i think that it's uh you know it's a
chill sport so it doesn't require like
running jumping squatting like stuff
like that like it's
you know old guys can swing the club too
um and then
all the bad parts you would have to
change so you'd have to find a way to
make it a
60 minute or 90 minute experience um you
would need
you know golf's cool because you can do
it by yourself you can do with one other
person or do with four people so that's
good i'd keep that
um you would not want to have it be
where you need like thousands of dollars
of equipment just to get started
um or like you know pay to go do this
thing and then you'd also want it to be
where a beginner can like
feel some sort of success and not just
like
like i went to a golf course what about
spike ball
too athletic dude you think you're still
thinking like you you have athleticism
still
you got to think about you 30 years from
now you got a bum hip
the testosterone that you've been taking
for 30 years has now wiped you out
you're you know you you're going to be
in a different phase you're going to
need a different sport at that time
i think it's got to feel like i just go
for walks
yeah but the walks don't have the thing
that the boxing is giving to you where
you
get to scratch the competitive itch and
you get to do
like kind of like um you get to feel
alive you can still feel like you're
doing something
uh walking is sort of like the most
basic i think you got to take like
shuffleboard uh shuffleboard level of
like
movement and make it a like outdoor
activity i don't know what's that one
sport that old people play that's like
um
bochie watchy i don't know what bocce
ball is maybe this is bocce ball that
i'm describing
but i feel like maybe something like
bocce ball is what's gonna what's gonna
pick up so we need to go to questions i
think
you're not a fan of the new golf i'm not
a fan of the new golf
dude i'm telling you it's gonna happen
you're gonna see the sport
rise in popularity amongst older people
and you'll be like
sean was right there was an appetite for
a sport for older people that's not
called
golf maybe but like i can't it's just
like such an
impossible thing to predict i mean like
i would be it'd be better
predicting which companies would be a
billion dollar company than which sport
is gonna be
who like who would have thought a sport
named pickleball was gonna be sick
yeah i don't know i would have put my
money on slam ball but you know
just to show what i know dan do we um
do we have uh what's it called did we
get the merch so we have stickers we
have shirts for
the tour yep we got stickers we got
shirts we got hoodies
and then my first business in college
was making buttons so i got some buttons
for you guys too
do you have the shirts with you i don't
they got shipped out yesterday they are
arriving
uh tomorrow into miami
okay great so austin austin no shirts
miami shirts everything's going to miami
yep
okay and what about um and what who's
the guy who uh designed the shirts let's
give that guy a shout out too
yeah let me uh pull it up dustin is his
first name
and he's like he's like a creative
agency or like a kind of a design
company or something
yeah he's got a creative agent from las
vegas i've tweeted out you know
hey give us some you know somebody give
some designs we'll
we'll we'll hook you up and uh his were
by far
the most kind of like favorited or liked
uh by people who said like you know pick
this one
these are the winners yeah dustin ionati
he's got an agency out in las vegas
called artisans on fire artisan's on
fire okay sweet yeah artist on fire go
check that out uh
and he made the post economic shirt
that's gonna fly off the shelves are we
giving this away are we charged for them
i didn't hear the the end result i got
square set up so
you guys tell me all right we'll just
head over down there
all right can i hear one a funny
observation yeah yeah
so i've been listening to you guys for
like a year now always on one and a half
x
so one of the weirdest things is having
to listen to you guys in real time
i've heard that before yeah sean sounds
like he's a couple drinks in
i can't believe that uh but i talk
faster than sam right
i feel like i'm i think we both have
nervous energy
well you talk really fast at one and a
half x yeah
that's fair i can't believe people
listen to this on on
speed this doesn't make sense to me all
right i gotta go i'll talk to you soon
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off on a road less travel never
looking back